now the met office has issued a red
weather warning for the southwest of
england tomorrow as the second storm in
three days is expected to bring winds of
up to 100 miles an hour to parts of the
uk thousands of homes are already
without power with major disruption on
roads and train lines after storm dudley
hit last night and on the way storm
eunice let's go live to houston station
now and talk to jay kelly the group
director of network rail jake thank you
so much for talking to us
at the moment what's the situation
across the network
so overnight colleagues have been
working really hard to keep the railway
open today tomorrow the met office has
issued severe weather warnings and we
expect very significant disruption so
our advice for passengers who want to
travel tomorrow is not to travel unless
they absolutely have to
and if they have to will there be trains
running at all
we expect very very significant
disruption tomorrow so so that's why our
strong advice is not to travel
passengers can choose to travel today or
on saturday and their tickets will of
course be honored
so how do they do that do they have to
come to the station
they
turn up at about the time that they
would expect to travel and their tickets
will be honored it's as simple as that
okay and so tomorrow if they do have to
travel how do they check what the
situation is
so looking at the national rail website
or looking on individual train operator
websites will give us the best
information possible but as i say that
despite the huge efforts of thousands of
people tomorrow to keep the railway open
we do expect it to be very very
significantly disrupted what is the most
damaging thing for trains is it those
high winds or is it the rain what is it
exactly
tomorrow we expect it to be very very
strong winds indeed uh it won't of
course just be the railway that's
affected but but but
if if trees fall as we expect them to do
then of course we'll have to clean them
away we'll have thousands of people out
with chainsaws cleaning them away but
inevitably uh there's going to be
disruption sadly
so that's storm eunice um storm dudley
obviously yesterday things have calmed
down just for a bit how much damage was
there following storm dudley
there was some damage and we had
colleagues out overnight right across
the country particularly in scotland
working really hard to clean it away
clean away the trees put wires back up
we're really pleased that most of the
railway was was open today but friday is
going to be different uh as i say our
advice very strongly is not to travel
okay jake kelly from network rail thank
you so much
thank you